ora in ora il my friends visto che
l'ultimo episodio andato così bene di te
thing over il porco il demonio ho deciso
ho deciso perché noi allora mi piace
sbarca a me piace sbattere la testa
sull'armadio una cosa che faccio per
svegliarmi la mattina quindi svegliamoci
numero delle moto in questo gioco che
erano ancora attivato quella era proprio
la più standard quella del martello ma
esistono robe tipo invisible player
sideway spot color rolling over i
ragazzi la cosa più stupida che abbia
mai visto che vi faccio vedere nativo di
che cacchio si parla perché veramente la
roba più bella faccione di un attimo
perché non ha un senso guardate che roba
allora è ok e veramente difficile perché
il fatto che lui si cada in piedi ogni
volta ti permette di fare certi tipi di
agganci con lui che che rotea binaria vi
assicuro che il gioco è veramente molto
più difficile perché stare in piedi
normalmente è impossibile prova ad
arrivare un attivo un punto decente ma
avevi assicuro che non ha un set va bene
se non morì per le cadute muori di
nausea amico mio cioè non so se non so
se si può morire di nausea però porco
demonio ok tutto perché poi il bello è
che non se non sta fermo perché non
vedete scivola vabbè ma anche una
roteare tra normale anche solo un
backflip va bene noi che vi fa per forza
tutta sta certo perfetto che poi tutta
sta roba non ha neanche un riscontro
stavo dicendo che tutta sta roba non ha
un lato positivo perché cioè non è che
roteando in avanti almeno fai più metri
quando ti lancino fugazze uguale se
fosse al contrario il gioco quindi se
dovessi cadere
dalla montagna invece che salire sarebbe
perfetto ma visto che devo salire sulle
robe il rolling over it è veramente
impossibile però sicuro ce l'ho fatta
non è vero non c'è un contabile ce l'ha
fatta perfetto ok ok non è male non è
male allora ok adesso potrebbe diventare
un po più difficile perché è contrario
mettiti al menti dei contrari dovresti
salire c'è salirà no dovresti salire di
qua lo capisco che è difficile però
provaci girati bravo effetto perfetto ce
l'ho fatta non avrei mai detto ce la fai
a salire qui porco il demonio sali sai 4
solito a porca vacca del soprattutto a
caso perché porco il demonio non si può
perfetto perfetto ok era quello che so
che non ti fa da una donna perfetta
appoggiati sono così fatto ragazzi non
solo appoggiarmi stai fermo conta oggi
fermo non puoi stare fermo su una
superficie proprio andata almeno
appoggiati ok ok che rolli ma appoggia
miroli dei gay c'è in nuce fatta bene
siamo arrivati già un punto
considerevole visto la difficoltà
rollare nella mappa però meno male ok ok
non ce l'ho fatta non fa niente non lo
so pensare finale visto gioco come sarà
differente di rotolare sull'antenna ma
non ci arriverò neanche forze non posso
pensare a rifinire il gioco ragazzi così
sta condizione di impulsi quella contu
rotola non c'è motivo di rotolare qua
c'è quello disco non c'è motivo non c'è
molto in tour rotoli senza un motivo
poco una situazione difficile ragazzi a
gestire la mia vita è difficile io
facevo youtube ma per campare faccio
video difficili che poi non lo dice ma
accenti sono dieci minuti per fare un
video a comparire ragazzi non ce la farò
mai se è veramente facile sapere
stavolta eccolo il fatto salire se
edificio è veramente semplice ragazza è
quello il discorso
ma la mente ci metti un secondo no non
si può fare non si può fare perché
rotolando non si fa c'è prima cielo
quasi fatta non so come perfetto ok
allora adesso fai una roba un po strana
perfetto attaccati ok ciao 23 perfetto
perfetto ce l'ho fatta e siamo arrivati
a un terzo nel gioco che comunque non è
male come risultato visto le condizioni
in cui sono le scale dopo ragazzi
preparatevi perché sarà la parte più
difficile di tutto sto casino
c'è veramente impossibile da solo
arrivarci ragazzi e problema figuriamoci
ok ok perfetto adesso sarà impossibile
dirlo perché il rotolo come un demonio
porco va bene invece è stato meno brutto
di quanto pensassi ragazzi incredibile
buono no no ti prego non sono gli ha
dovuto sono bravissimi non è male non è
male ragazzi non è male non è male nelle
mani normale non è male non è male non
mi posso appoggiare ma non fa niente
questa parte una cazzata
normalmente una cagata abnorme però non
si riesce neanche morti e non ce la
faccio ma bastano tre aree per qualsiasi
cosa ma non devi lottare per forza ho
capito che ho capito che devi che si può
roteare ma non devi farlo come tocco un
oggetto fi 26 netflix o fronti non ha
senso perché in ottica per qualsiasi
cosa stai fermo
ok ci ho messo 60 anni ragazzi e basta
rho bravo bravo non è difficile
beh madonna raga un cesso diventato un
problema sta regredendo fratello di
andare avanti
bravissimo però mai capito perfetto non
è vero
perfetto è stato perfetto ok ragazzi
siamo arrivati già ad un punto più
considerevole che è il l'orange inferno
nomi come come si chiama sta roba di
all'arancio che ripaga derby che già
rollo che è un piacere figurati se metto
la pentola su un arancio e potrebbe
essere un problema
no allora allora allora allora cambiamo
c
[ __ ] non è facile ragazzi non è
facile proprio non è vero devi andare
senza rollare performance di livellare
tutte le cose prof col demonio alla
ragazzi sia facciamo che in questo
preciso momento siamo quasi a metà gioco
che sono dei partiti di fini e non a
parte che odio di più
utilizziamo almeno qua i check point che
sono già nel gioco normale non li uso
però qua ragazzi fatemi la cortesia non
rompete le palle
perché vedete che già abbastanza
difficile almeno 40 che non è possibile
già di fatto che rotea a caso è un
problema sarebbe già difficile se
roteare se normalmente quindi solo con
la normale fisica figuriamoci se lo fa a
caso bene mercato non è male non è male
non è male perché adesso fai male perché
fai schifo
devi solo continuare normalmente
e allora vai giù mori buoni fine alla
tua vita di me ragazzi con definito sto
gioco che non
non esistenza e poi perché non c'erano
le monde quindi è stato proprio una
unione i reni di quelli fortissimi sono
forte ce l'ho fatta e stavo dicendo
esattamente difficile che poi quando
l'ho fatto ho preso due giorni di pausa
dai video giuro non ho registrato per
due giorni stata molto difficile
recuperare il tempo perso io ancora non
comprendo e continuo a non comprendere e
non nessuno me lo spiegherà mai come mai
il creatore il suo gioco visto questo
gioco inspiegabilmente ha fatto un
successo planetario ragazzi su ciò che è
stato scaricato ci ha fatto milioni sono
mike ardori di ferie o poi magari mi
sbaglio però porca vacca è stato un
successo e io riconosco la genialità dei
fatti è fallo un sequel così porca vacca
ci faccio altri 66 video e oplà non c'è
trucco non c'è inganno
arriviamo alla montagna che penso sia la
parte più non è vero penso sia va bene
fai quello che vuoi
devo farli tutta la parte questa e poi
con dei semi che accolse che voglio
vedermi la gara con sé che non è questo
col secchio penso non sia fattibile
proprio pc e non ci credo ce l'ho fatta
sono genio
ho fatto delle robe che non saprei di
fare ok a posto tutto tutto calcolato a
posto va bene ok perfetto purissimo
buonissimo che è stata un secchio bravo
bravo va beh non importa ci abbiamo
provato
se riuscissi a state per il primo è che
d'acqua ok ok che va benissimo
va a penly pagano così bravo bene di
fare questo è esattamente quello che
pensa
ti amo ti amo io chiamo penultima zona
la montagna io allora io ci provo è
credo sì credo non si possa fare non per
una questione politica credo che
rotolando non si possa fare per otto di
judy secondo me non la puoi fare la
montagna io ci provo ai ragazzi per
vedete qui ci sto mettendo d'impegno ma
secondo me questa dobbiamo scappare
però per forza di cose perché non si può
fare a me lo sto ragazzo non ci creò che
ok ok e buone buone vuole mandare una
cartina le ragazze ma cardinale manca il
finale manca il finale un finale non è
difficile c'è sì lo è in realtà è
tantissimo non ci ha formati marcelo e
check point qui non c'è paura di
scoprirlo perché magari non c'è cos'è
non mi ricordo se ciò il checkpoint
sull'antenna e devo ritornare all'inizio
della montagna non lo so non lo so e non
lo voglio sapere
sono condannate a giocarci per sempre
mai più sto gioco di buono buono madonna
madonna 6
si tratta cioè fatto già fatta ce l'ho
fatta madonna la gravità da gravità zero
signori signori proprio lui è stato
disastro ok ce l'abbiamo fatto ragazzo
era stato ma non basta basta basta basta
prossimo episodio di the thing madrid
con un'altra mode arriva molto presto
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi stato
orribile
un ritmo mai più una roba del genere
però no per un capo è pieno di scritte
dal canale schiacciate il tasto mi piace
rai ci vediamo poi se è proprio seguito
bella ragazza
[Musica]